with the last Jedi being released this
week it seemed like a perfect time to
discuss a question that myself and I'm
sure many other Star Wars fans have
asked over the years what exactly does
the color of a lightsaber mean if we
take a look at the Star Wars movies they
never really mention a reference the
different colors of light saber or what
they mean instead they simply serve as a
tool to represent to the audience who
the heroes and villains are if the
lightsabers green or blue then the
character is associated with the Jedi
and therefore a hero of sorts if the
lightsaber is red then they're
associated with the Sith and essentially
a villain during the making of the
original movies there wasn't a whole lot
of thought placed into the color of a
lightsaber the only reason that Luke's
lightsaber changes from blue to green in
the Return of the Jedi is because it was
very difficult to see Luke's original
blue lightsaber against the backdrop of
the blue sky outside of Jabba's palace
[Music]
when we move away from Cannon and the
movie universe and into the extended
universe the different colors of light
sabers are explained and we even have
some new colors introduced that did not
feature in the movies but we first seem
to understand how a lightsaber is
constructed before we delve into the
colors and what they mean in the heart
of every lightsaber lies a Kyber crystal
the crystal allows the user to
concentrate their energy through the
force all Kyber crystals are originally
clear but once they are attuned to their
user they change to a color that best
represents their skills and traits the
crystals are said to be inherently
attuned to the light side and will
attempt to resist any efforts made by
those of the dark side to use them
within a lightsaber the only way it
could be used by a member of the dark
side is by bending it to their will a
certain dominance through the force this
is referred to as making the crystal
bleed and results in the crimson
lightsabers that we associate with the
Sith
the blue lightsaber is undoubtedly the
most common in the Star Wars franchise
it represents a Jedi warrior a guardian
of the peace
Jedi's who wield the blue lightsaber
often use the Force on a more physical
level essentially a jack-of-all-trades
but a master of none the blue lightsaber
is ultimately a sign of a well balanced
Jedi and we see characters such as
obi-wan Kenobi Anakin Skywalker and even
Rey using a blue lightsaber the green
lightsaber is an indication of a Jedi
consular these Jedi had a very strong
connection to the force and they
preferred studying and reflect in its
mysteries they would often use numerous
forms of negotiation before resorting to
use in their lightsaber we see some of
those powerful Jedi in existence using
green lightsabers including qui-gon jinn
Yoda and of course Luke Skywalker
the red lightsaber and the SIF go
hand-in-hand at this point their
lightsabers are essentially corrupted by
the dark side as they were themselves
the red signifies intense emotion and
passion anger and hatred all things
we've come to expect from the Sith this
leads us to the rare and unconventional
colors one of the most notorious being
the purple lightsaber of mace windu
during the filming of the prequels there
was no intention of ever having a purple
lightsaber it was actually the actor
that played mace windu Samuel Jackson
who asked George Lucas if his character
could have a purple lightsaber so he
could stand out now the fans and
numerous authors ran of this idea and
with blue and red making purple it
seemed only fitting that the purple
lightsaber would represent a light side
user who was able to use elements of the
dark side we see the power of the purple
lightsaber when mace windu absorbs
Palpatine's force lightning and
redirects it towards him
with all of that being said it
definitely offers a more interesting
explanation than Samuel Jackson just
wanted a purple lightsaber to stand out
the yellow lightsaber is one that we
most commonly see being used by the Jedi
Temple guards these gods often referred
to as Jedi sentinels these sentinels
believed in a balance between skills in
combat and scholarly pursuits there is
no current explanation in Canon as to
how the yellow lightsabers are made the
white lightsaber is one that we see in
Star Wars rebels when ahsoka tano is
reintroduced the only known way to
create a white lightsaber is when the
bleeding process performed by a Sith is
reversed essentially healing the Kyber
crystal assume in the process involved
and the fact that it is used by ahsoka
tano
we can assume that it represents
Redemption the last lightsaber we'll be
covering today is the black or dark
saber an ancient weapon that was once
used by the Jedi it was eventually
stolen by a group of Mandalorians and as
a result it would be passed down through
their generations for many years we also
see Darth Maul use in the dark saber
during the Clone Wars and the origins
behind the saber are unknown unlike the
rounded lightsaber that we've come to
expect the dark saber much closer
resembles a blade or a sword the best
way to summarize what we've discussed
today is that all lightsabers begin
colorless and their crystals change
color depending on the traits of the
user if you were to choose what color
would your lightsaber be
I hope you guys enjoyed the video I know
it's a little different from the regular
content we cover but I do want to
explore some other fictional universes
that I find interesting as always I've
been your host mythology and fiction
explained